minneapolis is bracing for the
high-profile trial of derrick chauvin
the former police officer charged with
second-degree murder and second-degree
manslaughter
in the death of george floyd
i cannot breathe
video of the incident in which chauvin
is seen kneeling on floyd's neck while
floyd repeated that he couldn't breathe
sparked worldwide protests and launched
a national reckoning over police
brutality against black people in the
united states
the trial will be live streamed and
authorities expect it to inflame
tensions once again more than 3 000 law
enforcement officers and national guard
troops could be on call as the jury
deliberates
this is a difficult case in so many ways
people around the world have seen this
footage but
people in minneapolis have seen the
footage and what it's done to the city i
mean you
had riots a billion dollars worth of
damage to
businesses 1500 businesses were you know
somehow impacted by this
we recognize that throughout the trial
itself people will want to gather
they'll want to protest
they'll want to express their first
amendment rights and we want to enable
them to do so
safely and peacefully due to concerns
surrounding covet 19 and social
distancing
chauvin will be tried alone his lawyer
has made filings indicating he's not
guilty
so what kind of evidence will be
presented who might testify
and what is the bar for conviction here
are three things to know about chauvin's
trial
first video evidence is expected to play
a significant role
the prosecution is likely to seize on
the footage that shows chauvin kneeling
on floyd's neck
for around eight minutes as prosecutors
have pointed out previously
chauvin continued to kneel on floyd's
neck for about four minutes after an
officer said floyd was passing out
and for two and a half minutes after
another officer said floyd did not have
a pulse
relax i think
those last minutes after he's
already no longer not only not moving
but um
they can't even find a pulse how the
jury is going to react to
you know seeing that again in court as
probably one of the big moments of the
trial
the defense may also use video evidence
to bolster its case
though it is likely to focus on what
happened before those final minutes
you got him dang man put your hands on
top of your head
[Music]
chauvin's attorney has previously argued
that police body camera footage
shows floyd's struggling and actively
resisting arrest
stop resisting man i'm not yes you are
the defense has also pointed to footage
of floyd saying he couldn't breathe
before he was ever on the ground as
evidence that serious medical issues
were the cause of his death
medical evidence will also feature
prominently in the trial
but the jury may hear conflicting
testimony especially because two
different autopsies determined that
floyd's death was a homicide
but gave different reasons for his death
the defense
only wants to have the official medical
examiner's report
which talks about george floyd dying
because of
cardiac arrest complicated by the police
trying to arrest him and subdue him
and then also mentioning that he had
fentanyl and
methamphetamines and a heart condition
chauvin's attorney has pointed to that
autopsy to argue that floyd couldn't
breathe
due to a lethal dose of fentanyl and
possibly a speedball
and that other pre-existing conditions
combined with the drugs
most likely led to his death but another
autopsy prepared for floyd's family came
to a different conclusion that he died
of asphyxiation at the hands of the
police
well i think the question the two sides
are going to be going back and forth on
is what standard procedure and what is
police training so what is the bar for a
conviction
the most serious charge chauvin is
facing is second-degree unintentional
murder
that means prosecutors don't need to
prove intent to kill
but they must prove beyond a reasonable
doubt that chauvin intentionally
inflicted substantial bodily harm to
floyd which resulted in floyd's death
what they are actually trying to prove
is that
in the course of him being assaulted by
the police
he died so the police didn't intend to
kill him but by assaulting him
it led to his death chauvin's attorney
argued that the officers properly
restrained floyd because he was acting
erratically and posed a risk of injury
to himself
and potentially to the officers it
really is a difficult
thing to come to grips with because
everybody's seen this video
the officers were all fired immediately
but it's still very difficult to
prosecute
a police officer in this country legally
the stakes are high
if chauvin is acquitted the three other
officers may not go to trial at all
for aiding and abetting him currently
that trial has been delayed until august
lawyers for the three have made filings
indicating they aren't
guilty